octobre 2017 c'est la déferlante les
témoignages d'actrice américaine qui
accuse le puissant producteur de cinéma
robert wan steen d'inconduite ou
d'agression sexuelle éclater au grand
jour
l'ancien magna de ligue ou driver once
in est reconnu coupable de deux chefs
d'accusation de viol et d'agression
sexuelle
trois ans plus tard il prendra le chemin
de la prison
cette prise de parole a été le début du
mouvement mi to témoignages de femmes et
d'hommes qui disent moi aussi j'ai été
victime d'un crime à caractère sexuel
au québec le mouvement moi aussi
éclabousse l'animateur et producteur
éric salvail
une dizaine de personnes affirme dans
les médias avoir subi ses seins conduite
sexuelle
aujourd'hui il se défend en cours entre
autres contre des accusations
d'agression sexuelle sur un plaignant
gilbert rozon est aussi visée sur la
place publique
quatorze femmes portent plainte à la
police contre le président de juste pour
rire
une seule dénonciation est retenu une
décision qui choque l'opinion publique
et faire réagir la députée de joliette
de toute évidence il y avait quelque
chose qui ne fonctionnait pas que de
toute évidence cette confiance le était
tellement mise à mal dans le système de
justice risquait d'être encore plus mise
à mal véronique hivon se tournent donc
vers les partis de l'assemblée nationale
un comité trans partisan voit le jour en
r si elle est née mary sonia le but
trouver des façons de mieux accompagner
les plaignantes et rebâtir leur
confiance dans le système de justice
j'aurais aimé moi pouvoir bénéficier de
ce qu'on propose un rapport patricia
tulasne dont la plainte contre gilbert
rozon n'a pas été retenue a participé
aux travaux du comité
elle attend avec impatience le rapport
final et la mise en place des
recommandations qui en découleront il
faut que la justice s'adapte à la
réalité des victimes d'agressions
sexuelles
il faut que la justice soit plus
accueillante parce que c'est une
véritable épreuve de penser par le
système judiciaire
malgré les déceptions patricia tulasne
ne regrette pas d'avoir porté plainte
contre gilbert rozon le mouvement moi
aussi aura réussi à faire progresser la
société selon elle
j'ai l'impression quand même que les
choses ont évolué et que et que
peut-être que ces crimes d'agression
sexuelle et de violence conjugale vont
enfin être pris au sérieux
moi je trouve ce bénéfique que la parole
se libère que les gens n'attendent pas
40 ans pour parler envie de parler
d'enjeux
elle cite en exemple pénélope mcquade et
julie snyder qui ont récemment dénoncé
gilbert rozon accusations contre
lesquels il a répliqué avec une
poursuite en diffamation
mais pour la criminaliste daniel roy le
mouvement moi aussi et antidémocratique
le jugement populaire est basée sur des
faits qui ne sont pas vérifiées ne
laisse pas place à la défense détruits
défi et vous savez ça mène à l'anarchie
elle estime que la meilleure façon
d'obtenir justice demeure devant les
tribunaux ici valérie michaela bayne
radio canada montréal